hey guys so the Channel's been blowing
up recently which is amazing the only
problem is that now that my videos are
popular whenever I post a niche
borderline unhinged content none of you
watch it plus the channel just feels
like my job now so I'm starting a second
channel in order to make fun stuff just
for me hey guys the second channel has
been doing numbers but it just feels
like a second job now so I'm going to
create a second second Channel just for
me hey guys so the second second channel
has been doing numbers but you know I
just I think my heart is in podcasting
now hey guys my podcasting channel has
been doing numbers lately so I'm
creating a Clips only second pod related
second second fourth second Channel Hey
guys so it turns out my second second
channel of my original podcast third
second channel has been getting more
views than my original second second
second Channel therefore I will be only
focusing on this channel
just kidding I'm creating an 18th Vlog
Channel